et on va passer de ce club maintenant on
va parler sécurité routière et voitures
abaissement de la vitesse retour aux 90
km/heure suppression du permis à points
le sujet s'invite dans la campagne
présidentielle
et là nous rejoindre pour ce débat
pierre chasserait bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes délégué
général de 40 millions d'automobilistes
et vous allez bien sûr rester avec nous
tout au long de ce débat d'abord
première question pierre chasseresse que
ça vous surprend que ce débat ce thème
se sont invités dans la campagne
présidentielle comment vous l'expliquez
vous
je l'expliqué assez facilement bon de
manière très angles je vais essayer de
revenir sur l'historique en fait ce qui
s'est passé ces deux il ya eu cette
proposition de sandrine rousseau
d'augmenter d'une cinquantaine de
sorties les prix du carburant qui était
totalement délirante et lorsqu'on a
entendu ça mon équipe et moi-même à
l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes
on s'est dit qu'on devait réagir ou ne
pas se faire dépasser par la compagne
mais replacé l'automobiliste au coeur de
cette campagne électorale ce qui n'avait
pas été le cas il ya cinq ans l'idée a
été de d'aller voir les candidats
candidats qui n'étaient pas des
candidats placés aux extrêmes parce que
sinon eh bien vous galvaudé des balles
débat finalement retombe comme un
soufflet et on a eu une écoute à
l'époque sur une proposition d'anne
hidalgo c'était la proposition de baisse
de la tva à 5 et me sens comme produits
de première nécessité lorsque la
proposition était faite par jean didier
strike tous les autres candidats se sont
rendu compte qu'ils étaient absents sur
le débat de la mobilité et tout le monde
y est allé de sa proposition d'ailleurs
dans quatre cent des cas était
absolument la manne donc voilà comment
on a réussi à l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes a replacé
l'automobiliste au coeur du débat
maintenant elle va falloir continuer
parce que c'est capital la mobilité
c'est le sujet que tous les journalistes
finalement ignorait qui était capital on
l'a vu les dérives
qui ont mis le show à la france et du
carburant on va faire en sorte que cette
fois ci des politiques les candidats
n'oublie pas l'autonomie et on va
reparler toutes ces propositions rester
avec nous bien sûr que les archers
serait c'est vrai qu'il ya cinq ans on
ne parlait pas du tout le sujet de la
voiture laon on parle beaucoup c'est
devenu un sujet politique c'est devenu
un sujet de campagne alors c'est devenu
un sujet de campagne mais le sujet de la
de la voiture toujours été une source de
préoccupation est essentiel d'aider des
français il y a c'est j'ai retrouvé une
étude qui a été publié par les services
statistiques du ministère de la
transition écologique en 2020 et les les
personnes interrogées associés toujours
la voiture ou notion de liberté de
nécessité de plaisir plutôt que de
stress d'embouteillage et d'accidents ce
qui montre quand même que la la voiture
reste quand même une sorte de deux pôles
d'attention des français c'est aussi
depuis depuis toujours là ça prend une
dimension particulière parce qu'il ya eu
les gilets jaunes d'une part il faut pas
l'oublier 2018 c'est une crise qui n'est
avec les carburants avec aussi une sorte
de contrainte qui était qui était mise
sur les haies sur les véhicules et ça
revient aussi parce que dans la tête de
certains candidats
la voiture est à juste titre est une
façon aussi de séduire et de capter une
part de l'électorat alors on pourra
aller plus loin mais c'est de façon
différente si on s'appelle xavier
bertrand
ou d'autres mais ça devient parce qu'il
ya quelque chose à capter et on a un
mois j'ai une autre question après
moncler chasserait avons passé notre
reportage il ya c'est aussi un élément
de fracture entre des habitants de
métropole on voit apparaître deux
français sur trois ils ont plus de
voiture il ya un certain mais de
métropole qui qui copient copie cette
dynamique et qui vont là dedans alors
que dans l'ensemble de la population en
est à 84 % des ménages avec une
automobile donc c'est aussi un élément
de fractures et de deux de ciblage de
l'électorat qui est très important et il
ya un autre élément qui rentre en compte
c'est pour les élus locaux et est qui
qui qui va amener à politiser encore
plus ce sujet de la voiture c'est
l'installation en 2023 des autres des
zones à faibles émissions dans les
grandes agglomérations et dans les
grandes métropoles qui vont s ur 70% des
véhicules les plus anciens de plus de 10
ans et les diesel ça pour le faire
accepter à bas la france de gilet jaune
et à
dd des foyers et des ménages qui ont peu
de moyens et qui ont forcément une
ancienne voiture et qui n'ont pas
forcément les transports en commun
nécessaire parce que c'est très long il
ya eu de l'argent qui a été mis pour les
transports encore mais c'est très long
de faire un tramway c'est très long de
faire ça ça va être un vrai enjeu et et
beaucoup d'élus locaux sont inquiets là
dessus de comment on va appliquer ça et
le faire accepter dans ces grandes
villes mais on va en parler une question
claire chassé par rapport à ce que vous
me disiez tout à l'heure finalement que
vous avez trouvé de l'ecoute chez anne
hidalgo et chez sa proposition de baisse
des carburants alors c'est vrai qu' anne
hidalgo en tant que maire de paris elle
n'a pas franchement l'image de la mer
pro voiture c'est même l'inversé est ce
que du coup il ya une différence entre
la maire de paris et la candidate ou
est-ce qu'elle a saisi l'opportunité
dans cette campagne finalement pour
donner une autre image d'elle par
rapport à la voiture dont julien le
rappeler la voiture les français y sont
attachés
non alors déjà pour commencer il n'y a
pas de voiture mais des automobilistes
on ne va pas interdire avec menace de
démission 70% des voitures on va
interdire de circuler 70 cent des
français c'est pas du tout la même chose
j'en ai marre on parle d'un outil d'une
voiture derrière la voiture derrière le
volant il ya des chances j'en ai marre
qu'on stigmatise les métropoles
uniquement sur leur statut de métropole
on sait tous qu'on me passent tous à un
moment donné donc c'est une mesure qui
va toucher tous les français voilà ça
c'était très important derrière le
volant dernier s'il ya quelqu'un ya une
personne le deuxième
l'a été je suis pas dans leur tête en
revanche tout ce que j'ai su tout ce que
j'ai pu voir c'est pas été très
compliqué de convaincre anne hidalgo sur
cette mesure peut-être sans doute c'est
ma lecture parce qu elle ne l imagine d
une grande différence entre eux un
habitant parisien vote à paris et puis
un français tout simplement être
français les c'est posséder au moins une
voiture dans un foyer moi je pense
toujours cette question à ceux qui me
veut mais moi j'en ai pas le répond
aujourd hui mais la dernière fois que
vous êtes monté dedans cet écran je ne
connais personne qui est monté dans une
voiture il ya deux ans qui n'est jamais
remonté dans deux cuts donc derrière une
voiture liam immobiliste et ces débats
sont passionnants et passionnés parce
que systématiquement et bien on a lâché
explique il faut se passer de la voiture
et puis de l'autre côté vous avez 99%
dépenses avec mon besoin etc ont pas
envie de les publier et on va continuer
à parler de ce sujet avec notre
reportage à votre rencontre depuis
trente ans la mortalité sur les routes
françaises a chuté de plus de 15 mille
par an dans les années 70 nous sommes
passés à moins de 3000 victimes comment
faire pour réduire encore ses chiffres
sur quel levier peuvent jouer les forces
de l'ordre pour faire évoluer les
comportements violents au volant ça
vient de chez asus est une équipe de
gendarmes en eure-et-loir près de
chartres en voyant
cela fait 10 septembre que le lieu de
nombreuses d'abord veiller à la sécurité
des routes aujourd'hui son équipe a pris
position sur un péage de l'autoroute a11
l'un des plus gros axe de l'eure et loir
un endroit stratégique pour réaliser des
contrôles d'alcoolémie est-ce que vous
avez consommé d'alcool aujourd'hui à la
main lors du tout d'accord
parfait c'est bon pour un document pas
d'infraction pour aujourd'hui mais il
n'est pas rare de réaliser des contrôles
positifs même en plein milieu de l'après
midi
l'alcool continue de tués sur les routes
françaises il est responsable de 30 %
des accidents mortels commencé à l'heure
actuelle qu'on peut pas consommer
d'alcool ni de stupéfiants avant de
prendre le volant de son véhicule malgré
tout les comportements font que certains
des usagers de la route continue malgré
tout donc à outrepasser ses règles et
malheureusement s'entraîne à des drames
et des tragédies sont en route alcool
stupéfiants non respect des règles de
priorité les premières causes de
mortalité sur les routes sont toutes
évitable pour lutter contre les
gendarmes en plusieurs leviers la
prévention et la sanction qui peut être
graduée grâce au permis à points la
perte de points fait peur quelque part
c'est très dissuasif
donc on ne peut pas forcément comparer
avec nos voisins européens qui ne
disposent pas tous deux permis de
conduire crédité d'un nombre de points
néanmoins je pense à mon avis que en
effet ce nombre de points permet
seulement de dissuader la commission de
l'infraction par certaines personnes à
quelques mètres du péage une portion de
la nationale 10 limité à 80 km/heure les
gendarmes procèdent cette fois à des
contrôles de vitesse et sont
volontairement très visible la
dissuasion est au coeur de leur
stratégie contre la mortalité routière
le simple fait aujourd'hui d'être sur
cette votation a qualité à 80 sur la
pension soit calmée retrouvons suffit à
réguler justement les comportements des
personnes est automatiquement par eco
nous arrivons à nous placer à un endroit
puis un second puis un troisième et le
fait que cela circule que les gendarmes
sont en poste au bord de la route fini
par dissuader en 2020 2007 180 personnes
sont mortes sur les routes françaises
dans neuf cas sur dix un facteur humain
est à l'origine de l'accident
qui chasserait vous avez entendu bien
évidemment ce reportage est entendu ces
gendarmes parler de dissuasion
de certaines mesures qui font peur
notamment l'instauration du permis à
point pour vous les mesures instaurées
par les pouvoirs publics ces dernières
années elles ont été efficaces pour les
automobilistes
mais là j'ai vu surtout une séparation
entre
l'intelligence de ce lieutenant de
gendarmerie relatifs m'a plu dans son
discours qui il fait des choses qui sont
positives le fait d'aller ce qu'il ne
dit pas aussi c'est quand on limite dont
on régule la vitalisation de vitesse on
laisse une véritable marche de cohérence
on s'amuse pas à percer un tas de police
qui sont un petit kilomètre heure au
dessus en vitesse retenue donc ça c'est
très intéressant son message de lutte
contre l'alcoolémie contre les
stupéfiants entre le téléphone au volant
entre tous les facteurs type qui
pourrait éviter du un an un certain
nombre d'accidents ça c'est capital et
bravo à lui pour le métier qu'ils cèdent
et pour la façon dont il le fait avec
ses équipes en revanche à côté de ça
vous avez les mesures gouvernementales
baisser la vitesse de 90 à 80 km pas
franchement à quoi ça a servi à rien on
nous assure vendus partout on allait
sauver 450 me par an grâce à cette
mesure au final certains départements
sont repassés depuis à 90 d'autres sont
restés à 80 et d'autres nous ont fait de
l'hybride est un peu de 80 et 90 les
résultats en terme de sécurité routière
sont les mêmes alors quand j'entends des
bêtises comme ça qu'ils ont été mises en
place par l'état est bien derrière je me
dit il s'inspire et justement des forces
de l'ordre qui ont sans doute une
meilleure expertise de la violence et de
la délinquance mais un mot sur cette
mesure un quart avec l'achat serait le
passage aux 80 km/h et à mesure des
joueurs philippe effectivement ça a
beaucoup divisé élus locaux ça a été
compliqué sur les territoires et ça les
a beaucoup divisé parce qu'au début ils
paradent d'études et et même après la
mise en place des 80 km heure je pense à
une étude du crm en 2020 qui montrait
que ça faisait trois cent quarante neuf
vies sauvées donc au départ à à partir
des études scientifiques la mesure
semblait totalement légitime sauf
qu'elle a été très mal acceptée et elle
a été très difficile à comprendre sur le
terrain et surtout le gain par rapport à
cette baisse de 10 km heure était pas
forcément énorme non plus en nombre de
vies sauvées et ça a été très vite
politiser cette question là ce qui fait
que ça ça a rendu compliqué la relation
entre les élus locaux et les habitants
et 33 départements aujourd'hui sont
revenus partiellement ou totalement aux
90 kilomètres heure mais même le retour
aux 90 km a été compliqué parce qu'il y
avait tout un tas de conditions pour le
faire qui fait que selon les endroits
bas au final au début on avait une
situation claire où tout le monde était
à 90 et puis maintenant selon les routes
selon les endroits selon les
aménagements on va avoir du 90 90 et et
des délimitations totalement différente
et alexia pas que cette mesure et
l'institut aux docks ça fait une étude
pour le figaro pour savoir ce que
pensent et les français au sujet de la
voiture et des mesures attendues dans
cette campagne présidentielle but oriane
d'abord ce qu'on peut dire c'est que les
français sont attentifs à ce thème de la
voiture dans la campagne présidentielle
car selon ce sondage est bien 54%
d'entre eux accordent une place
importante aux propositions qui sont
faites sur la voiture par les candidats
à la présidentielle ensuite on va
regarder bien quelles sont les
propositions de ses candidats sur ce
thème d'abord sur la vitesse on en
parlait eh bien il ya une grande
majorité de français qui souhaitent
revenir sur ces baisse de limitation de
vitesse qui ont été décidées récemment
84% sont pour le retour aux 90 km heure
sur les routes départementales et 65%
sont pour le retour complet à 50 km
heure pour rouler en ville ce retour aux
limitations de vitesse davant et bien il
est proposé dans cette campagne par
nicolas dupont aignan est également par
eric zemmour alors toujours sur la
vitesse les français le tilt a baissé à
la limitation de vitesse à 110 km/heure
sur les autoroutes c'est ce que prévoit
le programme dany d'algos mais là elle
ne fait pas de strike un des français
sont contre largement à 75% ensuite
parlons du coût de ces autoroutes pour
les usagers et ce qu'il faut
nationaliser les autoroutes pourrait
bien baisser le coût des péages c'est ce
que propose jean luc mélenchon arnaud
montebourg marine le pen et les français
sont largement pour à 87% et puis on
finit par la fameuse question du permis
à points faut-il supprimer ce dispositif
c'est une idée lancée par eric zemmour
est bien là les français sont beaucoup
plus partagés c'est quasiment du 50 50
ans ouais merci beaucoup alex pour ce
sondage tiers chasserait qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce sondage variantes sur
la suppression du permis à prendre c'est
une proposition d'eric zemmour est-ce
que vous est-ce que vous pardon vous
êtes favorable et sur les vitesses on le
voit dans ce sondage les français
finalement ils sont attachés à
l'existant
écoutez quand vous avez un sondage 50 50
dans ma position c'est de défendre 40
millions d'automobilistes boulot donc je
dois du côté d'une écrasante majorité
comme je le suis pour l'euro à 90
km/heure par exemple ou contre
l'abaissement de la vitesse à 110
km/heure dans ces cas là moi j'aurais
tendance à penser que ce qu'il faut
faire c'est revoir le barème de points
notamment sur une infraction qui fait
beaucoup débat qui fait beaucoup de mal
et à l'échelle européenne n'est pas
c'est mettre en place une petite
tolérance pour les tout petits excès de
vitesse qui sont involontaires la
plupart du temps tous ces
82 81 vitesse retenue 71 60 au lieu de
70 toutes ces choses qui sont
insignifiantes qui ne sont pas pénalisés
dans les pays qui sont beaucoup mieux
que nous en terme de sécurité routière
donc plutôt aucun abandon total d'un
système on milite davantage pour quelque
chose cette fois-ci dibril des ti
consistera mais quand on parle de
voitures mais qui consisterait cette
fois ci à
revoir un petit peu le barème et à leurs
maîtres ou du jour on ne fait plus la
sécurité routière aujourd'hui comme on
la faisait ya 30 ans il faut l'accepter
et peut-être que nos pouvoirs publics et
notre grand bâtiment b sécurité routière
devraient s'en inspirer pour essayer
d'être un petit peu plus moderne aura
sanction
mais on voit les français ils sont
finalement attaché à ce qui existe sur
cette question de la voiture et
notamment sur les mesures mis en place
sur les limitations déteste ça passe pas
les mesures proposées par les candidats
n'ont alors certaines certaines sont
populaires ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
le faire déjà d'une part et puis ça veut
pas dire que ils voteront pour ça ce
pays est spécifiquement il ya quand même
d'autres sujets d'actualité je pense au
pouvoir d'achat je pense à
l'environnement qui rentrent en digne de
en ligne de compte ça veut mais ce sont
des mesures qui symboliquement
représentent des choses très importantes
parce que ça ça contribue à
faire appel à une sorte de d'esprit
français qui est partagé entre la
responsabilité vis-à-vis de
l'environnement mais aussi ce besoin de
liberté et la voiture c'est l'un des
derniers espaces de liberté on est on
est chez soi et finalement quand l'état
vient essayer d'imposer des contraintes
hong hong et on rentre chez chez le
français et ça le français il a toujours
un petit peu de mal avec c'est ce genre
de contraintes et même conclusion pour
ceux des barbares merci de l'archa
serait merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous tu cherches à serait délégué
général de 40 millions d'automobilistes
et c'est évidemment important d'avoir
votre point de vue pour ceux d
[Musique]